cool hello Team Coco I'm Mack DeMarco
how you doing this is some of my
favorite YouTube videos yeah
the first video that I've chosen to
share with you today is called cigar cop
2007 by a count cigar coach in this
video a grown man bearded man with Jim
Morrison asked aviators on vest as a
police officer is smoking a giant cigar
with a torch lighter and I believe that
this is a sexually pleasing to some
people who are inclined towards cigar
smoking I also enjoy this video as much
as the other people do
god bless this next video that we're
going to be checking out together is
called wet after work by a youtube
account Frank T and in this video it's
kind of a mystery man you never see his
full face maybe about this much of the
chin and the mouth
essentially the ideas he's come home
from work and he's still dressed in his
business clothing he decides to take a
dip in the bathtub with the clothing
still on slowly submerging the but the
but first and then getting a little bit
deeper to the tub I love this video it's
just strange to me and I probably will
never work in an office so for me this
is fulfilling that fantasy of life if
the next video we're going to be
examining today this video is called
forest walk 3 by youtube user jenny mud
and in this video another grown man
dressed in small dark colored underwear
and dark socks goes on a walk through a
muddy creek for me I don't particularly
like to get dirty in my own life so to
watch someone else you know get a little
bit nasty is enjoyable for me so the
next video this video is called working
on pickup by Wrangler zero one in this
video it's a man working on his I think
it's a Ford or maybe it's a babysit Ajo
Chevy Tahoe I'm not sure it's actually
quite a big fetish in some parts of the
United States I think where people are
obsessed with the shape of a man's ass
in Wrangler specific genes it gives a
very boxy shape and yeah
getting a little bit work done on his
car so you know two birds with one stone
for the final video that we're going to
be viewing today this video is called
muddin in the Creek 3 so the third in
the series this brings together the the
best of the Creek walking mud fetish
world and the Wrangler world the guys
wearing cowboy boots is wearing Wrangler
jeans he's also getting a little bit
dirty in that Creek for me it works for
you I don't know but you should check it
out
thank you very much Team Coco for having
me on your show and I hope you enjoy the
videos
god bless and say hi to your mother for
me oh this one's really good this next
one actually Oh